what is up everybody welcome back to the
cosmic wonder where we talk all things
marvel and mcu and if you thought that
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness was pretty creepy well it was
actually supposed to be creepier than
what we saw that's right the original
script for doctor strange 2 was creepier
than what we saw on this screen and it
originally had a different villain now
most people know that doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness originally had
a different director scott derrickson he
directed the first doctor strange film
and was set to direct the second and he
really pushed for this to be marvel's
first horror movie he had a whole script
pretty much entirely done but from what
we know unfortunately there were a
little bit of creative differences
between him and marvel studios based on
him wanting it to be a lot more creepy
than kevin feige wanted it to be but we
recently found out a little bit about
that trashed script from the actual
doctor strange 2 writer michael waldron
including talks about who the villain
was and no it wasn't originally going to
be wanda we also have some news about
some scenes that took place in doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
and how kevin feige wanted them in the
movie and these scenes connect to a
particular x-men one who actually had a
cut scene in multiverse of madness that
unfortunately we never saw and i'm sad
to say that that person was magneto i'm
sure everybody would have loved to have
seen him in the movie and would have
loved to see a connection between
magneto and wanda since there is a comic
storyline where magneto is wanda's
father so let's break down what the
original script was how the pandemic
affected it and what we could have
originally got which was an mcu where
the scarlet witch was not a villain so
let's dive into it and of course if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
can stay up to date on all the latest
videos so i think a lot of people know
that nightmare was originally supposed
to be the villain for multiverse of
madness but i think a lot of people
thought that once sam raimi and michael
waldron got involved after scott
derrickson left that's when everything
changed however we have recently learned
that that wasn't exactly the case when
sam raimi originally came on he was
still working with the script that scott
derrickson made and nightmare was still
going to be the main villain however the
pandemic changed all of that and we
learned about this in a recent interview
with michael waldron he talked about how
they needed a more multiversal adversary
for doctor strange to face rather than
somebody like nightmare and this is how
the scarlet witch became the villain of
doctor strange 2. something that became
kind of controversial but here's what
michael waldron said in an interview
with den of geek when talking about the
original script he said there was
different stuff i think it's been
reported that once upon a time there was
some talk of nightmare and stuff like
that but when i came on board it was a
multiverse story and so it was always
about trying to figure out who that
multiversal adversary was going to be so
right away he says people heard about
nightmare being the original villain
however when he came on board they began
to talk about possibly changing the
villain to somebody who was more
multiversal he continues to say when i
originally came on in february of 2020
sam and i inherited the story that had
been worked on by scott derrickson and
jade bartlett the original writer on the
project it had a lot of really cool
ideas in it and we were initially going
to just try and figure out our version
of that story in time to start shooting
the movie in may then cove it happened a
month later and the movie was pushed
which afforded us an opportunity to kind
of start over and re-examine what we
wanted the movie to be so kovid was
actually responsible for doctor strange
2 getting pretty much completely
reworked originally the movie was
supposed to be about nightmare being the
villain and it would have some
multiversal aspects to it but covet
allowed michael waldron and sam raimi to
write a completely new script which i
think is good because i think the
multiverse is going to be a huge part of
the mcu moving forward and if we are
getting secret wars and maybe four years
from now which i hope we are we needed
the events of doctor strange 2 to happen
the way that they did we needed to see
spoiler alert the illuminati and we
needed to hear reed richards talk about
how incursions happen because that's how
secret wars happens universes collide
and this is what they wanted michael
waldron continues to say it meant that
steven would have had some real
experience with the multiverse by now
that he had been on a multiversal
adventure already this isn't his first
rodeo so to speak so that kind of
re-contextualizes the way you approach
all of this he understands the dangers
of it more now of course what he's
talking about here is spider-man no way
home he had just dealt with the
multiverse in no way home so he was
somewhat familiar with the multiverse
and the dangers that accompanied it but
originally this was supposed to come out
before no way home so they had to change
the script so the original script was
going to deal with nightmare but it was
also going to be doctor strange's first
dealings with the multiverse so if covet
wouldn't have happened we wouldn't have
gotten the illuminati which is probably
debatably the best part of multiverse of
madness even though the scarlet witch
wiped the floor with them so here's
where the big question comes in would it
have been better if we got the original
script for multiverse of madness we
would have had less multiverse
adventures but the scarlet witch would
not have been the villain and she would
still be a hero in the mcu her future
would have been totally different she
could have still been a part of the
avengers which now is kind of
questionable since of course wang is the
sorcerer supreme he might have a problem
with her joining the avengers when she
comes back because let's face it there's
no way she's dead strange and wong are
going to be keeping an eye out on her
probably pretty closely now i personally
really enjoyed seeing the scarlet witch
at her full power and even though i do
fully believe that she is returning how
she's going to return and what her
future is is very unknown right now so
let me know right now in the comments if
you would have liked her to not be the
villain and would have had her remain a
hero and keep in mind there's always
redemption for people it'll take some
really good writing but of course she
can return and still be a hero and now
to talk about a really interesting x-men
scene in multiverse of madness which
didn't actually involve the x-men it's
the scene where doctor strange and
america chavez travel through a bunch of
different universes in the span of what
20 seconds 40 seconds they visit a lot
of universes in that time frame and one
of them is the savage lands a tropical
jungle hidden in antarctica that's also
a prehistoric land because it has
dinosaurs in it but the biggest thing is
that at one point in time magneto claims
the land as his own and he builds a base
there and then the x-men come and they
battle it's a big storyline and the
savage lands is mostly connected with
magneto and the x-men and as it turns
out kevin feige the president of marvel
studios is actually the person who's
said to put this in the movie in a
recent interview with the visual effects
team they told us about kevin feige
wanting the savage lands in the movie
when they said they proposed a jungle
and kevin feige said well it would be
cool if it was savage world so they put
it in the movie at kevin feige's request
we also got word that there was a
deleted scene with magneto the deleted
scene apparently showed him as wanda's
father in this universe the earth-838
universe once the illuminati learned
about dreamwalking and what the scarlet
witch could do they wanted to perform a
lobotomy on the scarlet witch of that
universe to make sure she wasn't ever
strong enough to dreamwalk but they had
to consult with her father magneto first
so that was supposed to be in the film
and now we know that kevin feige wanted
the savage world in multiverse of
madness a place that is heavily related
to the x-men now in 2019 kevin feige
announced that the x-men or mutants were
coming pretty soon he also announced
that the fantastic four were coming
pretty soon and we got reed richards and
multiverse of madness so i'm assuming
and hoping that the x-men are coming
sooner than later in the marvel
cinematic universe hopefully within the
next couple of years i'm also hoping
that we get the cosmic entities in the
mcu pretty soon and it's looking like
that might actually be the case you may
have also noticed that one of the
universes that they go through is a
universe where we can see the living
tribunal and as it turns out that was
also at the request of kevin feige when
the visual effects team was talking
about the worlds and universes they
created they said one was an incan
statue world which ended up in the movie
because kevin feige thought well that
could be a great world to put the living
tribunal in so that world became the
living tribunal world now for those of
you who may not be aware the living
tribunal is a cosmic entity that watches
over the entire multiverse and when
things get too crazy crazier than what
we saw in multiverse of madness he steps
in and he judges people based on their
crimes against the multiverse but here's
the catch he has three heads and they
all have to agree unanimously on the
judgment so if you're wondering why
hasn't the living tribunal stepped in
yet it could be because one well maybe
something wasn't that big to interfere
with yet or two maybe all of the heads
didn't agree because again it has to be
unanimous but we've now seen several
mentions and hints of the living
tribunal in the mcu in the first doctor
strange mordo mentioned the living
tribunal we saw a statue of the living
tribunal's head in loki then we saw him
in the recent doctor strange film and we
recently saw a statue of the living
tribunal's head and other cosmic
entities in the trailer for thor love
and thunder so i'm hoping that the
cosmic entities are about to become a
thing in the mcu they play a major role
in the comics and it's looking like
they're about to play a major role in
the mcu and since thor love and thunder
is going to explore other gods i'm
hoping they take that opportunity to at
least talk about cosmic entities so
that's it for all the latest news today
about multiverse of madness be sure to
let me know if you think wanda should
have remained a hero or do you like what
happened in multiverse of madness leave
your thoughts down below in the comments
and don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to stay up to date on all of
the latest videos of course for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof